he's never one of you here owes a 100
nazi zombie scalps
why I know you did tagged up you
probably shouldn't touch them right and
you might get blood on you Becky don't
do them do the shoot of that I don't
know what other thing
what's going on reject nation it's greg
out here it's John Humphrey here so
we're gonna check out today the call of
duty World War two Nazi Zombies feel
trailer
it's not much reveal I know it's coming
Nazis are practically zombies already it
didn't tighten you guys know my know
already we're not the biggest gamers
however whenever we go to Tony gills
place if there's a gamer on Twitch we
intended to play the play games like
this we play like the call of duty
zombie editions with Tony before we
really get it and we have one time it's
really fun to play with you guys
especially if you're learning still yeah
great playing with you guys I love read
respawning know we're wearing our tea no
evil shirt I'm going to say 90 nice does
mate yeah it's a a sponsored video but
you know they did give us these shirts a
long time ago such a shut up did you
know you had one this is warrior style
[Music]
I have seen a vision of our Fuhrer
future no and by mu
can you enjoy the program
[Music]
I have built more than just a new kind
of soldier we have created the devil in
boy
[Music]
oh boy just in time for Thanksgiving boy
howdy
that was a trail s John fill this I'll
call a nipple chill John just the tip
dang dude that was that was intense man
I would yeah I just want to watch that
trailer I mean I've always thought
that'd be easy call of duty zombie games
were fun and even the trailers were fun
and cool and with legit terrifying yes I
was like I don't know if I could really
handle playing this game by myself I
need to be in a room with people to play
this game you know absolutely scary this
is part of another game right this is
like a side piece oh yeah they're coming
I would call a duty World War two okay
okay yeah so this is the nazi zombie
version because this looks like this is
like it could just be its own complete
game it might be it looks like they
threw elements and Resident Evil if you
do need a member not knowing for sure
yeah my first one was part of black ops
you know it's like a like a like an
extra map like a side yeah I'm game if
that's their tradition I mean that's a
good way to hook people like the N
definitely look a lot more like a
Resident Evil type of game with the I
mean I wish we saw some gameplay that
would be cool I was one zero easy
gameplay oh yeah yeah a lot of these
modern game trailers yes sometimes I'm
like is this just for the cutscenes or
this also cut up in there looked at
least like brief flashes something over
the shoulders numb looked like it might
have been gameplay you know I don't know
if they changed it really works or
anything they have a Call of Duty World
War two Nazi Zombies wasn't there a
movie I am NOT a zombies in there right
there yeah there's just no this that's
no that's what it's called yeah and then
there's another like a found footage
movie with it's like a monster movie I
think called Frankenstein army and then
there's iron sky yeah do you want to see
Nazis from the moon if Nazis creating
the zombie epidemic just kind of makes
sense
knowing how experimental Nazis work I
kind of make sense did we go down this
path I've always wanted to make like a
like a really dark like kind of schlocky
nazi zombie yeah
or at least like like a Nazi experiment
horror movie the combination of those
aesthetics is so horrifying even just in
the beginning of their show you like the
lab and stuff and then zombie she'll be
like oh you're evil Nazi German
scientist yeah we already know that they
carried out some disgusting experiments
ah oh boy
I can't wait till Tony vices yeah right
I mean this yeah it looks like it's got
pieces of college duty and was an evil
and do really great gamertag so people
can actually play there really play
under Tony's account yeah we should
really never it's never we gonna invite
you know subscribers and actually hang
out with us and play with us online
I would love to twitch streams and then
I guess yeah I get all the job you know
which one because these games are like
intense and also scary so like there's
probably going to men of like stuff our
faces will be doing we have a twitch
account we just haven't use it well fire
it up but I'll be able to do this early
November that's all though we finally
here's in the damn thing yeah yeah just
watch these cookies on these and
probably getting but hell yeah are you
guys excited for world war ii nazi
zombies so you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell he
is - on Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of Blum
house.com
and you can check out our exclusive
perks and rewards at patreon.com slash
the real rejects would love to have you
join the community over there